a British couple is taking legal action
against the government adoption agency
for alleged discrimination Reena and
Sandeep Manders say they were told they
couldn't adopt because the available
babies were white and they're of Indian
heritage Charlie d'Agata spoke to the
couple about their difficulty trying to
start a family he is in London charlie
good morning good morning it's hard to
think of a couple more suited for
adoption in the Manders we visited them
at home both successful professionals
big house with plenty of empty bedrooms
and yet they were discouraged to even
try they say because of the color of
their skin about the only thing missing
in Reena and Sandeep Manders life as a
child to share it with not just oh we
want to have a family we want to have a
child but also to do some to some good
as well do you know give a child a
loving home heaven knows they've tried
Reena underwent no less than 16 rounds
of IVF treatments well we did get
pregnant well it's unfortunate I
miscarried at 10 weeks yes after six
years of heartbreak of trying and
failing they decided to adopt but when
they contacted the local governments
adoption agency Sandeep said he was told
he shouldn't bother to apply you're not
gonna be prioritized here so you should
probably go look elsewhere I told you to
look elsewhere yeah because their view
is that there's a there's a lack of
children in the system and the children
they caught tend to be white so they
would have many white stroke European
adopters available for looking for
children so we wouldn't be prioritized
in short white babies go first to white
couples though demanders say they didn't
care what color their baby would be to
your you were pushed to the back of the
line yeah right at the start so this is
this is even the ability to apply in
fact they say they were advised to try
India even though Sandeep and Reena or
both proudly British born and raised
neither even has family there I just
felt as though everything we'd been
through this was another obstacle it was
it wasn't just nautical it was
preventing you from moving
at all there was no you know for me that
was it was like where do we turn now
this wasn't a hurdle this is a brick
wall yes exactly
their local politician Theresa May who
since become Prime Minister wrote a
letter of support on their behalf
the couple has now filed legal action
against the adoption agency claiming
racial discrimination the agency denies
discrimination saying they properly take
into account the profile of children
available for adoption and given the
disparity between the large number of
prospective parents and small number of
adoptees it's appropriate to prioritize
those who have the best chance of
adopting a child
it is absolutely considered best
practice and ethical to take race into
account that's different than saying
it's the controlling factor at
impertinent is the author of adoption
nation and president of the u.s.
national center for adoption and
permanency I think we live in a culture
where we understand race can be an issue
but in child placement and child welfare
in this country and by law in Great
Britain this is not supposed to happen
rena says it's the only time in her life
she's ever been made to feel different
they're now planning to adopt a child
from the United States where they have
family and a new reason to hope only
when we are coming back from the US on
an aeroplane with that charm the hands
and all the paperwork and everything
cows only I think then I will it will it
will actually sink him before then you
know it's gonna be a turbulent journey a
journey that may finally have a happy
ending now we have to point out here
that nine months after they were first
turned away the Manders did receive
notice that circumstances had changed
and there may have been children
available after all but by then they
were already in the process of adopting
in the US Nora
Charlie thank you Wow nothing worse than
wanting a child and not being able to
have one and then adopt and and the
agency would rather the baby not have a
home than to go to a home with parents
that really want you and I really want
you yeah that doesn't make any sense
UK yeah it sounds like the story's gonna
have a happy and yes then yeah we will
update you on what half
there